I used to do drugs I still do what I
used to - they'll legalize any drug so
long as that drug keeps you producing
that's all I give a [__] about is
production you're kicking out enough
boxes at the plant whatever keeps you
doing that keeps you vaguely content
sitting in a cubicle go ahead and
fda-approved I have a job where i
alphabetize insurance forms forty five
hours a week and I noticed I couldn't
concentrate so well at my job so my
doctor put me on adderall and now I can
just breeze through my workday I don't
even notice that my empty life is being
pissed away underneath fluorescent tubes
I have no highs or lows I've no good
stories they're just but I'm getting a
lot of stuff done I probably the most
boring person I know but look at me
produce I just go ABCD efg hijk I might
be gonna take a pill but add you're not
concentrating because that's [__]
boring and that's a natural reaction to
boring don't concentrate find another
way you're gonna make a living get bills
to pay by less [__] and find some fun
suck a dick you got a baby it'll suck
again I'm talking to you in particular
whatever it spin around the brass pole a
few times whatever say you saw the
Virgin Mary in a grilled cheese sandwich
and sell that [__] on eBay as a grip in
the system there's always a scam you
don't have to do it just because your
guidance counselor told you you'd excel
at it come over this country is so
bereft of imagination anymore [__]
those pills well I have a lot to do with
it I would I was a real [__] when I was
a younger girl I slept with a lot of
guys and it's not something that I'm
proud of but I'm in therapy now and my
therapist put me on wellbutrin and
effects her and she explained to me
through our sessions the reason I
so promiscuous I come from the military
family so I didn't have a stable male
role model in my life I have a low
self-esteem because I'm a little bit
chunky
and I try to compensate for that by
having sex with a lot of different maybe
you just like the [__] wailing in and
out of your untrimmed winter ready New
York sludge pot that's fantastic
take some [__] there's nothing wrong
with it free fun that's what it's there
for
don't take a pill take the clock for
that maybe your clitoris is there for a
reason psychedelic mushrooms yeah like
how many times yeah you are you know not
recently not in my adult life no no
little Mulaney trip to you no I haven't
done them in the eight years I haven't
done them in a year all right
I feel like you've done him ah yeah
that's how we came up with this yeah I
was a little rascal
I was a little rascal when I was a kid
yeah and yeah I took them I like to you
haven't really grown out of that though
you're still Mullaney me I know I'm a
leading man
so that's your message the Hollywood
that's my message to the LA community
Becky sent you out here to make sure
people know that yeah my managers girl
named Becky so yeah took him once with a
group of friends and I laughed and I
laughed and I laughed and that night we
were at a diner and we had a Styrofoam
cup and we poke two holes in it and we
put nickels in there and then straw
hands and we named him Floyd Nikolai's
and all night we'd talk through him
going you guys want to get some beers
then you know psychedelics are strange
they have a reputation where if you take
them you see dragons and stuff and
that's not true it's more like patterns
start to make a lot more sense yeah I
like you'll be like that shirt is a
genius bad comedy yeah just that other
[__] yeah that other [__] that's right I
live to listen I'd the hardest years of
my life for the three or four years when
I was doing straight mainstream [__]
television shows because I thought I
want to be like a Danny Kaye or some
when my dream from a kid was still like
that I want to be in the movies and go
like this for people and I didn't know
that I write like this I didn't know my
head was different I didn't understand
that I thought if I thought about it at
nine years of age it must still be valid
when I'm 21 but it wasn't and I and I
finally that clicked in from the acid
thank God for acid
[Applause]
that hard stuff is [__] around here
to get me [__] but no one ever gets me
acid that's why that's why they put it
on that list of bad drugs cuz they know
it opens up the mind it can be dangerous
I ain't saying it's not dangerous in
some way you take too much take the
wrong kind girl what do you get your
acid from I don't need it anymore
because it's a self-limiting drug it's
the kind of drug that you take it a few
times and it tells you that's enough
we're cool now we're happening and
that's what happened to me as opposed
like this
I just say goodbye to my drugs and
liquor no more liquor and drugs for a
while for a while more liquor and drugs
Scotch was Scotch was like a bittersweet
kind of hey scotch I won't be seeing you
as much every now and then a lot of
Christmas probably right and then
marijuana I was like marijuana listen
look let's just let's not hang out for a
while and we'll hang out when she gets
out of college when she's married and
has kids
we'll be the cool stoner grandpa then
like it gets high and then I'll just
I'll just spend my days telling lies
about bands I never saw how about we do
that well that'd be fun I saw Radiohead
with six people I was like the first
show they ever did I think you're lying
grandpa but the hardest one to say
goodbye to was LSD that was weirdly that
that broke my heart I've had the most
fun on LSD and by the way I'm not afraid
that I'm gonna be on acid and put her in
a microwave or something it's that what
I'm afraid of is her first memory of me
will be me on LSD and I don't want that
to be in her book of memories having
breakfast with her dad
and he looks like what do you have in
there Lucky Charms
alright let me tell you the whole
conspiracy behind Lucky Charms man so
alright look in the bowl for okay see
the little crunchy wheat things and they
have all the vitamins and minerals right
so they're not that tasty are they yeah
well those are shaped like little you'll
notice take a look yeah they're shaped
like little crosses and little fish the
XO symbol that the Greeks Tru over their
doors to signify they were Christian so
the Romans wouldn't kill them and then
the little marshmallow things and those
are those are fun aren't they they sure
are but they have no nutrition they're
just sugary and colorful and those are
shaped like pentagrams and moons and
clovers traditional pagan symbols so the
propaganda that Lucky Charms is trying
to lay on you is that the path to
Christianity which is no [__] fun but
they will give you vitamins and keep you
regular and the path to paganism which
is colorful and bright and sweet but
it'll rot your teeth and make you fat
you're welcome and then
that's when she'll say yeah but they add
it there's balloons and rainbows now and
I'll go you're the devil and you just
made daddy pee his pants good job